we do kind of all gel like a family as
it were
many of the harry potter actors didn't
have to try too hard while acting since
they were so similar to the characters
they portrayed
do you ever stop eating
i'm hungry
while some could argue a young rupert
grint was being lazy and getting
distracted on set it seems to us like he
was just going full method with his
character in one of the earlier films
the actor was doodling with his quill
instead of taking notes and while that's
innocent enough i drew this rather
unpretty picture of ellen rickman while
rickman was standing right behind him
it was definitely an awkward moment the
picture wasn't nice either i exaggerated
a few of his features
but at the end of the day it was pretty
perfect considering their characters and
it only solidified the fact that both
actors were pretty well cast even though
rickman was far from evil
fortunately this has become a fond
memory and the snape actor recognized
grint's talents and kept the doodle i've
made him sign it and i have it in my
possession
if we're being honest professor snape
scared all of us when we were younger
and considering just how great an after
alan rickman was it's no surprise that
he was really intimidating a young
radcliff on set the poor actor was
constantly needing to remind himself
that it was just a movie and there was
nothing to be scared of
nothing's real luckily it worked out
pretty well and only made radcliffe's
job easier
why pretend fear when alan rickman makes
acting terrified so natural
professor snape managed to work his
magic on another student as well draco
malfoy poor tom felton was totally
overwhelmed by rickman's snape-like
attitude as a result it took the actor
years of working with rickman to
actually feel like he could approach him
and have a chat
when you're a youngster that's going to
be very very daunting after doing a
couple of years of movies the director
felt the young actors were ready to get
even deeper into their roles so he had
each of them write an essay about their
characters
who we thought our characters were why
they did the things they do their
background their feelings every single
one of them took it shockingly seriously
and the final result just proved how
perfectly each of them was cast
harry was always full of passion and
drive so it's no surprise radcliffe
wrote an honest and serious piece i felt
so pleased i've done it i've done it
emma watson pulled a hermione and handed
in 16 pages worth of analysis on miss
hermione granger rupert grint might just
have won the assignment though he didn't
even bother with an essay i didn't do it
now why would he skip out on this well
according to the wrong actor his
character wouldn't have written an essay
we can't argue with that logic when
you're done just give it a tap and say
mischief managed
whether it was on screen or off both the
phelps twins and the weasley twins
always made sure that mischief was
indeed managed in the movies fred and
george were of course always using the
fact that they were identical to their
advantage pretending to be each other
when appearing as themselves the phelps
twins would continue the ruse only this
time they'd pretend not to be related at
all
no
right and i would be met at the audition
process
while they were good at fooling people
they couldn't get away with pulling a
fast one going through security in a
european airport
it's a puking festival
the twins not only swiped some puking
pastilles from the set but they also
tried to travel with them and faced a
fair amount of suspicion maybe the
farthest the two actors went though was
during their downtime on set one day the
performers along with a young bonnie
wright stole the walkie-talkies from a
construction site nearby and they sent
all the workers home
needless to say this was one prank that
didn't work out so well
maybe the phelps twins considered it
research
a stone that may skull stops you from
dying no wonder snape's after it are we
surprised that the young emma watson had
not only every single one of her own
lines memorized but both harry and ron's
as well it would be one thing if she
kept it to herself but the truth came
out while filming when the actress
couldn't help but mouth along with her
co-star's lines it made for some very
adorable behind the scenes footage
the actress didn't even realize she was
doing it and was the reason they had to
do so many takes of this scene
watson and hermione granger were clearly
two peas in a pod and turned out what
might just be one of the sweetest
bloopers we've ever seen
what a good liar is
from their very first interview it
became pretty obvious that the team
behind harry potter had found the
perfect actors these young performers
were so inexperienced and found
themselves right in the deep end
answering questions about how they plan
to spend their first paychecks their
answers almost feel as though they were
scripted for their characters
emma watson was no surprise the most
sensible of the three i'm afraid i'm
gonna stick it in a bank until i'm 21.
the wizarding world was a totally new
concept to harry potter so it doesn't
come as a shock to know that daniel
radcliffe felt a bit over his head as
well no i don't have any idea
a goof just like his character rupert
grint went ahead and gave what was
definitely the most ron weasley answer
we could think of we're gonna get paid
muggle money and i don't really
understand it are we sure these young
actors didn't write any of their own
dialogue
there is something
but it can't be
whether he was being ron or rupert he
was pretty often awkward whenever the
actor had to talk about his character's
relationship with hermione it seems like
grint blushed just as much as he did
anytime ron was confronted about his
feelings for her it's gonna be strange
the friendship between the trio is
obvious seeing their interviews and the
dynamic between them is surprisingly
similar to their relationships on screen
while ron and hermione did finally end
up happily together by the end of the
films the whole storyline was an awkward
affair for the actors and grint was just
as shy as his weasley alter ego neither
of us were looking forward to it the
poor actor couldn't even catch a break
from radcliffe and watson since they
could call him out and tease him at the
drop of a hat
while she may have denied it when she
first began playing hermione granger
emma watson has always been just as much
of a high achieving bookworm as her
character i used to sit down in
interviews and be like i'm not like her
at all
the actress loved school so much she
even contemplated leaving the franchise
to pursue her studies fortunately the
production team worked it out so the
actress was able to continue on with her
schooling we have a feeling hermione
would have been pretty proud of watson
and all of her academic achievements
and i'm malfoy
draco malfoy
while normally footage from behind the
scenes would show us actors behaving as
themselves felton occasionally decided
to rock his evil malfoy alter ego i
don't like the common folk looking at me
you know
while we aren't big fans of how
pretentious draco is we definitely don't
mind tom felton's brilliant portrayal
even if he wasn't filming
[Music]
it was never really too hard for rupert
grint to act terrified of spiders i'm
definitely afraid it's terrified yeah
granted the props they built were so
good anyone would be scared
unfortunately for him ron faced a lot of
spiders so it's a good thing he didn't
have to act brave about it i would
actually cry
if one came near me one of the worst
moments on set for grant was when doing
tests for a scene that involved a baby
tarantula being placed all over the
actor's body the experience was far from
enjoyable for both ron and rupert
can we panic now the harry potter
franchise might just have the most
perfectly cast actors it's no wonder we
fell in love with both the characters on
screen and the actors behind their
performances
fortunately the evil ones we're looking
at you malfoy weren't actually like
their alter egos